to be alone in nature
feeling either the window the water
against whiskey hearing the sounds that
seem to stick from the sails gives you a
taste from your original intent before
we created this concrete jungle and
these schedules we were mentally free
when freedom is greatly expressed in the
creation around us what a privilege it
is to be portable hump of happiness
every Wednesday
who remembers the wolf champ in 2004
nobody but at that time it seemed to be
the biggest deal in the world I have
struggled with the vanity of surfing for
a long time the vanity of achievement of
competitive success running your
contests does not influence anyone
else's life except yours
that's awful isn't it some of you might
ask why bother but I believe that there
is a way in which we can turn vanity
into purpose and that purpose is what
keeps me going
that purpose is why I wake up in the
morning and decided today and then we
can go
there is a point in everyone's life
while there certainly was mine where
there is no more room for logic whether
it is having the faith to believe that
the Sun would rise the next day faith is
evident all around us the ocean teaches
you the system very well
it teaches you that some things are way
out of your control and the best thing
you can do is to overpower the fear and
take that leap of faith
thanks Bruce for watching my latest hump
of happiness with Bianca be thunder
click here to subscribe for weekly
uploads and let me know what you thought
in the comments below see you next week